a lot of talk about the oscars today but
now it's time to talk about my favorite
part of any award show the fashion so we
had to call in an expert
[Music]
[Music]
is joining us today to talk red carpet
fashion i'm can i have an intro song
like that that's amazing you need an
i think you have one though don't you
thank you so much for being here i'm
really excited and uh you brought the
look today i am loving this you should
have been on the red carpet i've been
telling them for years we got to get you
out there so a lot of fashion to talk
about always some hits always some
misses but are you ready to jump right
into it we gotta break it down yeah and
i love the misses
it's always kind of fun right like you
know what we're talking about so okay
first up
laverne cox what you thinking i thought
she looked wonderful it's the first time
she did it for e she was on the red
carpet and i think she got it all right
she has the black gown with the big cape
you cannot get more academy award than
that and black always looks the best on
the red carpet i was just going to say
you can never go wrong with black it's
always a safe bever it looks amazing all
right next up zendaya
zendaya i just love the way she made it
young yes you know because sometimes you
wear a gown you it makes you maturely
yeah but no look at that with
a lot of skin this year yes it was a
little bit too much skin for me but
otherwise that style is amazing i
thought she looked great and valentino
made that and i feel like she's one of
those people who can just do no wrong
exactly my eyes everything she wears and
she has the body for it right and that's
the other thing if you can do it do it
yes she can rock it all right next up on
our list i think it's nicole kidman
right yes what do you think in armani
ahmadi made that color for her so that's
really impressive you know what i'm
saying yes but she always knows how to
look she knows what her body looks like
and what things look good on her body
and to have her own color of blue i i'm
totally jealous wow that i had no idea
that that was a specific color to her i
wasn't sure at first when i thought
about it but i think that makes it
really unique and cool so i'm on your
side for that there you go all right
next up is my girl jessica chastain best
of the night for me i i loved how she
had like sequin ombre going down right
all the way into that lavender color and
then the big puffy bottom
she looked like a movie star what do you
think about the ponytail i i would have
done my hair a little bit differently
i'd have some curl in it but as far as
just the dress i thought that's
hollywood for you you know a lot of
people forget what they're doing and she
knows what she's doing apparently yes i
loved it i would have liked to see her
hair down or maybe a half up or
something but hey she can work the
ponytail she's another one in my opinion
she really can do no right and one thing
i want to say is yeah i don't want to
see the girl next door when i watch the
show i want it over the top like that so
you go oh it's fantasy yes and i'm all
about sparkle so she really brought it
exactly all right next up we got jada
pickett smith okay now i'm really afraid
but she was my she was my pick for last
to me that was made by jean-paul
gaultier who i love as a designer i just
thought the dress was wearing her it was
just too big it looked like coffin
lining for like a leprechaun yeah it was
a little much it's a little much that
green all solid no nothing else but i i
want to make sure i say i love her
because i don't want to get smacked any
time today yes
just be a little careful what we're
saying today absolutely
nothing personal that's right we love
her all right so i picked a few of my
choices and i want to see if you agree
or disagree so let's start with lily
james i actually had to do a double take
i didn't recognize her with a brown hair
she's wearing versace
i just i'm a huge cinderella fan so i
just get cinderella vibes from her every
time i see her what do you think i think
she's absolutely stunning and i think
that would have been one of my picks if
i didn't if i needed an extra that's who
i would have said it's just so fantasy
that i love it oh okay we're on the same
page i love it makes me happy okay next
up we gotta talk about timothy chalamet
we're in agreement i liked part of the
album okay yes the sequence tell me what
you liked i loved the jacket it was
louis vuitton i think but
i mean what's the deal with the no shirt
under it okay so i like the entire look
i thought he looked amazing it was very
expensive you know just put that out
there but it's more for the grammy
awards okay you know more rock and roll
yeah you can have a little bit more fun
yeah
i believe you really should be dressed
for the academy awards it's the top of
anything you could go through well that
leads me into my choice for worse dress
kristen stewart what was up with the
shorts i mean that's not something you
wear right yeah so here's where i think
she got it wrong if she tried to make it
young like zendaya yeah but it could
either go really nice or really bad and
think unfortunately in her case for me
it went really bad yeah it just looked a
little messy and especially being there
for spencer and such an exactly like i
really wanted to see it well at least
when they got home they didn't have much
to take off that's true easy to do
exactly well this is really fun to break
it all down and before we wrap up this
segment you have a lot going on oh my
god about your brunch legends everything
well i'm starring every night in legends
of concert and where the theme is divas
so we have cher lady gaga um
uh
who else adele celine dion so it's like
action-packed it's all live it's got the
band so it's a real vegas show you got
all the divas i love it and real quick
where can people see your brunch show
and my brunch show i'm opening up at the
west gate hotel i'll get your tickets on
ticketmaster.com and we'll be doing two
weekends april 24th the 30th and may 1st
it's going to be an upscale brunch you
the customer will be the star
the room is done elaborate and the food
is good a lot of times you go to
brunches and that's the complaint the
show is nice but the food's not up to
par yeah westgate went all out and we
have an amazing menu oh well so fun
frank thank you so much for being here
for break it all down um you are my
fashion hit for the day thank you for
joining us we'll see you next time and
sally i'll send it over to you